wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
er weiß schon heute morgen sind immer
wieder als neubeginn
so
sind aber der münchner tafel
wir müssen wissen schnell machen es ist
interessant zu sehen wie den leuten
denen es nicht so gut geht geholfen wird
die kehrseite von münchen die leute
machen das ehrenamtlich hier leute
mithelfen zu dürfen
neben mir steht der peter perzl der dass
hier mit organisiert und wird uns heute
ein bisschen was erzählen zur münchner
tafel
wir versorgen in einer woche 18.000
bedürftige der stadt münchen mit
lebensmitteln das heißt die gäste der
tafel sind leute die also an der sozial
grenze leben
die lebensmittel die wir verteilen
können sind aber überwiegend gespendet
von sponsoren sprich großhändler
discounter die wir hier alle in der
stadt ansässig haben wir sprechen da von
einer menge von 100.000 kilogramm an
lebensmitteln die wir in einer woche zur
verfügung stellen
es läuft alles sehr strukturiert wirken
hier alles schritt für schritt und
organisiert also vor uns ist der
jonathan und der wird uns mal ein
bisschen was erzählen warum hat es hier
eigentlich macht ich bin student
halbzeit gerade freitags habe ich keine
vorlesung gehabt und ich finde gerade in
münchen sieht man irgendwie so wenig
arme menschen wenig leute die irgendwie
bedürftig sind und dann hatte ich die
idee behilflich zu sein und diesen
menschen zurückzugeben
wir zahlen jetzt hier ein bisschen essen
auf
wie lange sind sie schon hier ist wie
oft kommen sie hierher also jede woche
ich bin circa acht jahre einmal freitags
haben sie heute schon ihre ration
bekommen ein lichtermeer strom das geht
immer nach nummer und dann muss man halt
warten bis mit trankow
was sie hier sehen ist eine wochenration
für eine person
die ist schön verpackt mit allen sachen
die man braucht brot kartoffeln äpfel
alles verpackt in einer kiste die wird
sogar leuten die nicht mehr so stark auf
den beinen sind nach hause geliefert
dass ich doppelt toll finde es war mir
sehr lehrreich heute bei der münchner
tafel mithelfen zu dürfen und ich freue
mich dass wir dabei